(Whimpers)
(Barks)
Ughhhh, shut up Annika!
What time is it...
OH MY GOD I'M LATE.
(Mechanical whirring)
No, I'm good.
(Happy music)
I'll take you
Right and... there!
(Happy music)
He's gonna love this.
(Door slams)
(Music stops, Flowers crash loudly to the floor)
YOUR CHEATING ON ME!?!
OHHOHO
Alright George, who do you think you are, HUH!?
HELLO! (Snaps fingers in face)
Hello?
Oh.
Time's frozen.
Ok.
(Heavy metal music)
Perfect
Two can play that game.
(Heavy metal music)
(Birds chirping)
(Happy Music starts playing)
Ooooh (giggle)
Hello
Damn
Oh my gosh
These are for
you
There you go
ok.
Oh man
Oh mannnn
Oh my goodness
One, two
Twelve of them?
Oh god
You know what?
I'm gonna help you out
I'm gonna oil you up
Just to
help you out
(Sexy music starts playing)
*quietly* Alright, let's do some of this...
Wow! (Laughs)
Wooo
What were you made? In a museum?
My ex would be so jealous.
oh my god
I'm single
(Happy Music starts playing).
Oh!
Boop!
What happened?!?
Huh?
Huh, I've always wanted to try this
Do WHAT? What are you trying- AHH
TAKE IT LIKE A MAN GEORGE AHHH
AHH!!! WHERE DID YOU EVEN GET THE WHIP?!? A-H-H!!
Now, can anybody tell me, WHERE is Amanda?!? (Whispers) What?
Hello! :]
Hello! Hello! Hello! Please come in, please, please, please, okay
Alright everybody, lets go! Get ready, listen.
Ready!
On you...
(Quirky music)
(Whispers) Oh my god...
(Whispers) Did you see that?
That was beautiful!
(Clapping) That's a wrap! Huh! That's a wrap! (Clapping)
Thank you!
We'll see you tomorrow!
Okay!
At 7 am.
(Suprising effect)
(Love music)
(Outro music)